How does the supplement amude aloevia help with cancer? So aloevia amude is a great supplement
for cancer because it comes from the aloe plant that is, you know, pull it up here,
um, that is a, um, uh, and it's pulling out just the polysaccharides. So, so understand the polysaccharides
that are, there's certain group of polysaccharides that are amude modulators that really help
bring balance to the immune system. So an amude modulator is something that when your immune system
is suppressed in the case of cancer, it boosts up your immune system. When your immune system
is hyper expressed in the case of like an autoimmune disease, it can actually help bring
down that immune system and bring it back into balance. That's the beauty of an amude modulator.
Um, now the benefits that mushrooms have in that is, is the, uh,
component of the mushroom that's called polysaccharides and the different types of mushrooms have
different chained polysaccharides. So poly means many saccharides as sugar. So don't think it's sugar
like it's glucose, but it's a polysaccharide. It has a completely different, um, expression of the
body. It doesn't break down into glucose. So it's not going to affect your blood glucose,
doors are going to feed the cancer. So a polysaccharide works on the amude response in your body,
but it is, they found in research, there's a certain chain polysaccharide. I think it's like 300
saccharide molecules, 300 to 500 saccharide molecules that have the best expression on
immune stimulation. Now different mushrooms work differently because they have different polysaccharides
in them. Um, so the, uh, turkey tail tends to be better for, for, um, certain cancers, and
Rishi is different for different cancers, and my talk is different for different cancers. Um,
that's why I like from, from a mushroom standpoint, is to use a blend. Now turkey tail has been found
to be much more beneficial for breast cancer. That's why we'll tend to use turkey tail for breast cancer.
But there's polysaccharides in more things than mushrooms. Um, the aloe plant has a lot of polysaccharides
in it. Um, and this company, aloevia has patented a way to separate out the polysaccharides between,
I think it's 300 to 500 size polysaccharides. And that's all that's in the immune product. So
it's taking three aloevia immune a day is like taking, you know, 12, um, to 18 just standard mushroom
capsules a day because you're getting very specific immune modulating, immune stimulating
properties in the aloevia immune. Aloevia immune is a powerful cancer killer. Um, you know,
I've spoken about it a lot because that is the product that I used for my cancer along with black
sand blood root and number of other things I did take mushrooms as well to get a full balance of
different polysaccharides too. Um, but we have a lot of people in the aloevia immune product. It's a
great product. So the benefit of the immune aloevia immune is the polysaccharide size. So it's
the size of polysaccharides, the number of polysaccharides in that polysaccharide chain that makes it
unique. Um, and that fraction of polysaccharide is patented form of separation. So, um, there's, uh,
I think they share it with one other company that has rights to use it, but otherwise you won't
find it any any other way, any other place. So,